das wird das ende vom lied wird einfach
für sauber erklärt feierabend ist auch
viel billiger so reden wir drüber mit
einem der wenigen deutschen autoexperten
ohne führerschein mit ohne zuschauer
oder was sagst du zu den diesel
fahrverboten wie zb demnächst in
stuttgart droht das ist ja gerade aus
stuttgart will möglichst zügig weg ich
weiß nicht ob das der weg geht alles zu
verbieten also ich glaube man muss doch
irgendwie das alles hat beschleunigen
ist meine je schneller man fährt desto
eher ist die umweltverschmutzung vorbei
also immer noch verbieten finde ich den
falschen weg fährt er kaum noch einmal
in den großen städten warschau und was
willste im stau fahrverbot also ich
meine das hat irgendwie nicht internet
nach beginn der hamster zu humpeln also
da beginnt die diskussion ist ja
offensichtlich sehr hitzig in
deutschland man merkt immer wieder die
deutschland eine sehr emotionale bindung
zum auto an sich was sagt das über und
auto fahren das ist was besonderes ist
kann man nicht vergleichen mit fahrrad
ohne fahrer fahren das ist nur veganes
reiten das auto
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das auto ist die die verlängerung des
menschlichen penis
das wäre auch alles schon so erogenen
aufgeladene stoßstange und kolben
schaltknüppel also im auto darf der mann
wirklich noch man sein noch der
klassische roten holger und für viele
weise zu kurz gekommenen männer ist das
auto dann eben auch ersatz also es ist
ersatz für untergebene wenn man kann das
auto treten
es ist ersatz für freunde man kann es
auch saugen also dann möge niemand rein
greifen wie wir für dich als visionär
der verkehr der zukunft aus es wird sich
in der gesetzeslage einiges ändern also
um den verkehr zu beschleunigen sollte
man glaube ich so ein bisserl was ändern
ich meine rechts hat vorfahrt das sollte
bleiben aber links auch können wir
gleich zwei paaren beschleunigt und die
antriebe werden sich stark in richtung
elektrizität
das ist ja klar also über den hybrid ich
fahr momentan hybrid und das ist ja das
ist benzin strom also völlig
überflüssiges elektrizität gewöhnt also
die
mit der strom benzin verloren pressebox
und bremse durch die bremswege station
wird also negatives tempo erzeugt ich
beschleunige negativ also wie soll ich
sagen
je mehr ich bremse desto weiter kann
nicht vorne wenn man also meine lange
strecke zu fahren hat
also bei langen tanken da muss man sich
erst mal vor eine stunde in die garage
zum bremsen der akku ausgebremst und
dann geht's ab wie schmidts vorteil also
das sind spitze 200 das ist natürlich
braucht in der stadt
jetzt hat der bundesrat der deutsche
bundesrat heute entschieden computer in
autos dürfen auf deutschen straßen
demnächst funktionen übernehmen
stichwort selbst fahren des autos wäre
natürlich eine option
das autonome fahren finde ich positiv
ich bewerte es positiv denn es macht den
verkehr sicherer
der größte risikofaktor ist der mensch
gerade alte kraftfahrer machen jetzt
nicht so auch sehr junge kraftfahrer und
natürlich etliche kraftfahrer jeden also
[Applaus]
die zahlen sind eindeutig
fast alle weiblichen unfallverursacherin
sind mittlerweile frauen aber dazu kann
natürlich auch ist ein zeitgewinn vor
allen dingen selbst fahren das auto da
kannst du sagen du vorne los ich bleib
zu hause dann kannst du am handy gucken
wurde es den chor umguckt irgendwie und
wenn keiner geht fährt dann ist es
leichter dann verbraucht weniger benzin
und ich traue mir an einem auto das ganz
weit fahren kann und alle passen rein
aber keiner fährt mit weil eine soldatin
[Applaus]